we need to keep activating our pieces
rookie seven is correct
whoa whoa throw some
during the air conditioning on wow 8 000
from my boy
this is exactly what we practiced for
oh he just lost oh
damn girl moist with 8 000 welcome guys
charlie thank you so much
we got another huge 1am raid from my boy
the slayer of dragons the conqueror of
worlds
welcome guys and you come at a great
time we are doing i'm doing my speed run
[Music]
and we are playing hey harem so let's
play d4
we've been mostly playing e4 i want to
also showcase
queen's gambit here we go this is the
queen's gamut and he responds with the
slav
defense i'll talk a little bit about the
queen's game but after
the game e6 is the queen's game of
decline c6 is a version of declining the
queen's game called the sloth
and in the slav um we continue to offer
up that c pawn by developing our knight
so we developed both of our knights this
is the main line theory of the slav
and now e6 is called the semi slav
very theoretical opening now white is a
a major choice here between several
different
variations i'm going to play what i
actually normally play as my main line
and that is the fiance the bishop this
is the g3 variation of the sloth
you shouldn't put too much weight into
this i'm this is a theoretical line
uh where white fianchetto is the bishop
which is a i don't know a really
reasonable thing to do here
notice what i'm doing he can take the
pawn on c4 at any moment
and after the game i'll show you guys
how white responds to that
okay so how should we proceed with the
development here
uh there's yeah this is very similar to
the catalan so at this point
um i've i've had enough of offering that
pawn
to him so how can we ensure without
releasing the tension which would help
him
that that c4 pawn is safely protected so
we don't have to worry about it anymore
let's go b3 exactly
now in terms of this bishop where should
it go where do you guys think we should
develop this bishop depending on what he
does
yeah okay we have two possible
options here one is the sort of kinetic
energy
move one is the oh sorry and one is the
potential energy move now
bishop g5 would be a little bit useless
due to h6
bishop f4 is the kinetic energy move but
let's play a potential energy move
this should be two you guys look at this
and say well what look at this girl this
bishop just biting on granite what am i
doing
but here's the thing i'm now going to
orchestrate a plan
that involves trying to remove that pawn
from d5 so that my bishop on b2 comes to
life
how do we remove the pawn from d5 well
we need to orchestrate e4
well we can't play e4 because it
blunders the pawn but hey that's why we
put the bishop on g2
who can spot a way to prepare e4 knight
to d2 is correct rookie one would be
also fine
but this also opens up our other bishops
so it sort of does several things at
once
um and once we play e4 he's gonna have a
very hard time
keeping the pawn on d5 because it's
going to be attacked from so many
different sources
he can but it's going to be hard we're
actually threatening e5
ourselves his knight is kind of trapped
and if he takes
then we have the later possibility of
going d5 ourselves
and guess what that bishop on b2 it's
kinetic its potential energy is going to
be transmuted into kinetic energy that's
why we put it there
and can we play d5 immediately we can
actually consider a g6 is a very
weakening move i don't know why he did
that but
uh let's first improve our position
let's make a couple of general improving
moves we can propose for me a
sort of a a standard connecting
kind of move rookie one is fine i also
like queen d2 in such positions
in order to put the rook behind the
queen rook d1 uh that would help prepare
the d5 pawn break and we can put the
other rook on e1
let's do that rook ad1 no need for
anything crazy queen h6 would be
interesting but he could chase that
queen away with bishop f8 i don't
particularly like that
uh and at this point we already very
seriously need to consider
d5 because this bishop's diagonal in
light of the fact that he's played g6
is tremendously strong but the thing is
uh
we want to be patient in these positions
what my coach always says prepare slowly
attack fast
right now we're preparing slowly so that
when we do play d5 it comes with far
greater effect
than if we rush it was i rushing were
you rushing or were you dragging
now we have improved all of our pieces
our rooks nicely placed
queen well placed bishops on the long
diagonals
knights connected with each other even
without calculating a single variation
i can almost guarantee you guys that
this move is going to work
because our pieces have tremendous
potential energy his pieces are all
clustered on the back couple of ranks
i've made this move on the basis of
intuition alone we have an ideal
position so let's sacrifice the pawn
in order to rip apart this diagonal for
our bishop and because he's played g6
he's going to pay a very very steep
price for that not quite my tempo
but now comes the stage where we need to
we need to respond precisely
let's not get too casual here let's not
get too cavalier
what should we do in this position how
do i think about this well first of all
uh it's important to notice that our
bishop on b2 is not yet operating to its
entirely full potential here
because there's a knight on c3 that's
sort of blocking that bishop's access to
his king
so that's like priority number one is
there any way that we can yeah let's go
knight to b5
let's open up that bishop so that it it
it
you know it does what it's supposed to
do here so
let's see how he responds now he does
have queen c2 that's kind of a nasty
move i saw this move don't worry
and i have a response to that prepared
but
um you know he can also play knight
takes e4
and we'll deal with that if he does it
also something i saw
yeah but you say i would never see that
but but that's exactly okay so queen c2
is less scary than it looks why because
he's not actually threatening anything
in regards to our queen
and if we look at our two knights we can
yep knight ed6
that's simple and again transformation
of the advantage you guys might look at
this and say well wait a second
you're trading queens isn't that good
for him isn't it good for him to trade
queens
technically yes but our pieces are so
strong that even without the queens we
still have
a tremendous level of initiative uh
you know our bishops are great his
pieces are all kind of loose
and i've mentioned many times that the
higher rated you are the more you have
to be able to do that
okay oh my god now ladies and gentlemen
what should we do in this position
what should we do in this position how
do we continue our initiative
we need to keep activating our pieces
rookie 7 is correct
whoa throw some
turn the air conditioning on wow 8 000
from my boy
this is exactly what we practiced for
he just lost oh damn girl
moist with eight thousand welcome guys
charlie thank you so much
we got another huge 1am raid from my boy
the slayer of dragons the conqueror of
worlds
welcome guys and you come at a great
time we are doing i am doing my speed
run
some of you probably know what that is
um and after this game we are in the
middle of a game
where i am about to finish crushing this
guy
okay so as you can see my pieces here
are incredibly well placed but we've got
to be very careful
and and we have to separate uh sort of
the reality here what is going on
gym 10. we're popping off with ten
gifted subs
oh i can't keep up with this let's just
take his pawn here that would be the
simplest thing to do rook takes f7
and we're simultaneously attacking his
knight on f6 now there was a very
tempting move here that i'll explain
after the game which would have been
wrong
and i'll show you guys why it would have
been wrong 100 bits from i am that
victoria 11k viewers
this is amazing this is just what i
needed and i really really appreciate it
uh love charlie's community and you guys
are always welcome in my stream
uh i'm honored i'm absolutely honored so
welcome welcome guys okay so rook c6 is
a great movie he's actually playing
incredibly well private butters
five gifted let me focus on not losing
this game though let's play bishop takes
f6
smashing down that knight and what's
going to happen here i actually didn't
play this very well
uh but that's okay man miller with five
gifted
holy smokes holy smokes
okay so we are in a better end game
right now
now believe it or not he's actually
beaten back my initiative
so white is still better and after the
game i'll explain why i'm starting to
play very quickly here because
look at my time i've got 36 seconds and
in chess if you lose the game on time
you lose the game that's tantamount to
losing
so it's very very important to play very
fast here and i'm starting to push my
pawns up
curious chimpanzee but this is
unbelievable hype
now we're basically pushing our queens
our kingside pawns my kingside pawn
majority
we are now we're getting the king up
because it's an end game
we need to activate our king this pawn
on d5 if you guys will notice is very
weak this guy is really good
i have to say he is he is playing like a
gm
in this game okay but we're going to
smash your pawn to g6
that pun is a protective passer i'll
explain everything i'm doing
i know people's head is probably
spinning at this point
and we are going to give a check and we
are going to get checkmate mr bowser
thank you for the prime
wow okay um i'm not getting my t
yet okay uh
most of you have seen that show this is
the queen's gamma this is the opening
called the queen's gambit
okay why is it again but what is the
gambit a gambit is when you give up a
pawn
uh and you give up a pawn in order to
achieve something in this case
why does white give up this pawn who can
explain that to me
yup and i also have been active on
youtube something that charlie
you know has also helped me tremendously
with to which i owe him a great
debt of gratitude yeah white controls
the center
so white gives up a pawn to control the
center that's the typical reason for
a gambit uh that's not the only reason
for a game but if you think about the
king's gambit which is the same thing on
the other side of the board
basically you do the same thing you give
up a pawn to control the center
controlling the center
one of the most basic things that you
want to do in chess is it a bad thing to
capture this pawn
no this is called the queen's gambit
accepted that's a legitimate variation
but my opponent declined the gambit and
played c6 this is called the sloth
this is called the slot we are almost at
100k subs i cannot believe all the
support that's been coming my way
recently
it's been absolutely incredible black
has several ways of whoa
sorry black has several ways of
declining the gambit you can play e6
that's called the queen's gamut decline
and c6 is called the sloth
okay i also do coaching but not taking
students right now i'm
got a very very full schedule but yeah
that's sort of the main thing i do
now basically we're both developing our
pieces right now black plays the move e6
reinforcing his control over the pawn on
d5
and and opening up the bishop on f8 now
that bishop can get developed those of
you
you know who are not too experienced uh
you you've probably heard this but
when you first start a chess game what
both sides want to try to do is develop
their pieces
right you need to develop your pieces
and put them on good squares because the
ultimate objective of a chess game is to
deliver checkmate to the king
to put your opponent's king in a
position where it is in check it is
attacked and it has no escape squares
but in order to do that
if you compare chess to a war you need
to deploy your army
you're not going to win a war if your
soldiers
sit around starbucks drinking pumpkin
spice lattes
and you know and shooting the breeze you
need to deploy them to good squares
and that's basically what you do in the
first i love pumpkin spice lattes
uh that's my favorite drink in starbucks
but
hey you know can't always do that
there's a time and a place for that
and during a chess game is not the place
for that but basically we're both trying
to get our pieces to active squares
g3 is called fianchettoing the bishop we
bring it to
the big diagonal so we're both
developing castle castle
and now we have to decide where to put
this bishop on c1 it's still on its
initial square
we need to develop this bishop and as i
talked about before after b3
which defends the pawn we have two main
choices about where to put the bishop we
can put it on f4
which is a nice nice square for the
bishop but we put it on b2
remember potential in kinetic energy
questions now we're
going over the game so questions now but
wait until i reach
the point at which you want to ask the
question so um you know try to ask
questions
on the current moment that we're at
why'd you defend c4 so late that's a
great question uh let me mute the sub
sound for now
um as the alerts catch up to us
now basically black could take the pawn
at any moment
okay black can capture the pawn am i
blundering this pawn no
this is basically an extension of the
queen's gambit and what white usually
does
here is either e4 to control the center
that's actually the main move here e4
controls the center
and in terms of trying to win the pawn
back what black can do in such a
position is go
b5 the idea being to support the pawn
with its neighbor
how can white go about stopping b5 from
happening
yeah i'll talk about that in a moment
why can't play the move a4 that's a very
typical move i've had this position
before in my tournament games
then you can go after the c4 pawn with
something like queen e2 capture c4 or
even knight d2 takes c4
so either of those moves is fine this is
the theoretical continuation
if black plays b5 here i want to
introduce to you guys
a very important principle and
the principle is that when your opponent
spends a long time playing on
the flank playing on the side of the
board you often want to strike in the
center
because when he's expending his
attention
doing random stuff on the side of the
board usually he weakens his center and
that's exactly where you want to strike
so
e5 would not be the best move here
because it would it would help him
get this nice little outpost for his
knight but the move would be d5
and now he cannot avoid the center
getting open look at how we're striking
through everything
he has to open up the center this bishop
gets super strong
black's position kind of starts
collapsing here and uh this
is just not good for black also this
pawn hangs so
that's a principle to be aware of uh
it's not a law
but it's a good guideline for when your
opponent is playing
on the side of the board um
well moving the bishop to g2 brings it
on to the biggest
on to the longest diagonal in the
chessboard that's kind of completing the
fianchetto
there's more to get into here but um
since the game was long i want to keep
things keep things moving thank you
fenbine gold for the 200 bits
now what if b4 after d5
great question well before after d5
let's see
so here uh it's important to avoid that
knee-jerk reaction right
he's attacking our knight but rather
than moving it we can capture on e6
and counter attack his knight and then
if he takes back
what we can do here is we can even
consider sacrificing the knight
we can simply leave that knight on c3
and make a move such as knight d4
now what the hell am i doing have you
gone crazy daniel are you just giving up
your night no
where is this night heading where is
this night heading
what am i doing here well i have gone
crazy that happened when i was born
but yeah we want knight take c6 here
and uh we attack the queen we attacked
the pawn and we get a massive attack in
response to
s compensation for the piece right
that's what compensation is when you
sacrifice a piece
and you have some sort of advantage in
return for the piece such as an attack
and i have a very aggressive style so i
like doing that i think that's a very
good idea in blitz
right so knight takes e6 would be um
very very strong
there's a lot more to get into here
sorry i keep doing that i pressed the
wrong
button there's a lot more to get into
that um but uh
that basically is the lay of the land if
black takes on c4 so let's proceed
with the actual game bishop b2 fiancato
and the other bishop and just to
reiterate
why am i putting the bishop on a square
where it literally just
stares at the pawn because wow
5480 i can't believe that self-calibers
in general because the point is
what we're gonna do in the future is
we're gonna prepare the move e4
and the idea of preparing e4 is to
remove his pawn from d5 and in turn
eventually we're going to push our own
pawn to d5
and open up this bishop where it's going
to be incredibly strong that's actually
exactly what happened that's literally
exactly what happened
so watch knight d2 in order to prepare
e4
now we go e4 we force this pawn out of
d5
and now we prepare the breakthrough d5
and we do that by improving all of our
pieces we patiently do that we don't
just
go d5 immediately we prepare slowly and
attack fast
our rooks go to the best squares and
here comes the boom goes the dynamite d5
right we're ready to play d5 because all
of my pieces have occupied ideal squares
and i have to give tremendous credit to
my opponent throughout the speedrun my
opponents have been
playing very well which is awesome and
in this position my opponent started to
defend
very very well i was quite impressed so
what happens
this is upon sacrifice this is upon
sacrifice
because i can't take the pawn with my
knight he'll just take it with his
knight thank you
fenbine go for 300 bits yeah rook ac one
might have been more accurate i kind of
played rookie d1 on autopilot but i
didn't know that he would play queen c7
i think he played it because he saw that
i played rook a d1
and we can't take on d5 because a bishop
takes e5 small piece of advice
when you're trying to figure out whether
you can play a move
don't only count the defenders and
attackers it also depends on what
specifically is attacking a pawn
here there are actually more attackers
on the pawn than there are defenders
but we can't capture with the queen
because we give up the queen
right so you can take one d5 and say oh
great well
i accomplished d5 well congratulations
and give you a medal for that but
hey you gave up a queen so be careful
about that okay but that's okay
now we play knight b5 what is the idea
of this move the idea is to attack his
queen
and open up the diagonal for our bishop
now our mission has been accomplished
and our bishop on b2 is an absolute
monster
so could somebody help me understand
what would happen if he took on e4 with
his knight
counter-attacking our queen as you guys
think about that i am going to
run and pour t i will be back in 10
seconds my voice is starting to go i
need that i need that t
russian style give me two seconds now
the move here the simplest move is rook
takes c4
thank you for waiting i can't believe
charlie rated me that man is an
absolute legend i'm super pumped right
now the rook takes c4 is the move
what are we doing well remember we're
still attacking his queen
and now we're attacking his bishop queen
h6 looks very good because we're
threatening checkmate
what's the problem with this move the
problem is that
he plays bishop f8 and he
counter-attacks our queen and
and defends against the checkmate this
is complicated but i hope that everybody
can understand what's happening here
basically both queens are hanging we
have both queens
you know i got got gun point here knight
takes c7 and knight takes d2
queen d4 bishop f6 is the same problem
he again attacks our queen in defense
checkmate thank you alan miller
for the gift to mark roar and
uh the idea of rook takes c4 is that we
eliminate his knight and we attack his
bishop
he has to move his queen while defending
his bishop
and he can do that by playing queen c5
and
the position remains very complicated
but what we can actually do here is go
b4
we're attacking his queen and trying to
disattach his queen from the bishop
and once he takes my knight and i take
his bishop
this is a very very good position for
white because we are now finally ready
to put our queen on d4 and threaten
checkmate wolf razors thank you for the
prime so this is super complicated
but basically white is in charge here uh
i don't want to
bug ourselves down on the default with
the with the details
but uh clearly black is on on his last
legs so he goes queen c2 we go 90 to d6
forking his rook and his bishop
he trades queens which is good for him
but our position remains dominant
and after rook c7 we go rook to e7
uh involving our rook putting it on the
seventh ring thank you melon miller
attacking the pawn and potentially
threatening to capture his knight
okay and again because we're at a
relatively high rating
i know that a lot of people have
questions about specific moves and i
know that i'm not answering all of them
guys but please do understand that
since i'm trying to keep this uh
instructive as much as possible i have
to find a compromise between talking
about the details but not
boring people to death and discussing
them for an hour because i could talk
about this game for an hour but i want
to keep things going smoothly
so i'll try to give the gist of the
complications without
talking about it too much hopefully i'm
finding the balance
reasonably well and after he moves his
bishop away
i actually committed a mistake um
i thought from a distance that i would
be able to play bishop takes f6 i
thought that this would be winning
why notice that this is a pin
if he takes our bishop he loses his rook
but what did i miss here and i didn't
play this move
i simply thought that i would play it
but what does black have
i appreciate it guys thank you rook c1
check so he gives
us the check we have to deal with the
check thank you rando
ben dodendo and now he's able to take
our bishop
because uh our rook is his rook is no
longer hanging
moreover he's attacking our knight this
is not impressive for white at all
so instead of this i doubled back and i
said okay instead i'm just going to take
his pawn on f7
but now he found a super good move i
thought that his position collapses
we're attacking his knight
legitimately now because we're now
attacking him with two pieces
but he plays this incredibly annoying
move rook c6
and here's why i defined type one and
type two
undefended pieces just as a reminder one
very important thing to notice in any
chess position
type one and type two undefended pieces
a type one undefended piece is a piece
that is literally not defended by any
other pieces
so in black's position there is only one
type one undefeated piece
which piece is that which piece is the
type one undefended piece the only one
it's the rook on c7 why is that
important well because it's pinned that
tells us a lot about the position
but something that a lot of i think
chess authors don't do is define type 2
undefended pieces
which are a piece which is a piece that
is defended by
only one other piece a piece that is
defended by only one other piece and
pawns don't count if a pawn defends a
piece it is defendant
so the knight on d6 right is type 1
undefended and the rook is type 2
undefended
so this mechanism right here is
incredibly flimsy
that's like you know jimmy garoppolo
throwing a path like this is not going
to end well
and what he does here is he attacks the
knight the knight is undefended and
the knight itself defends the rook you
guys can see how flimsy that is right
that's not going to end well so if i
move the knight i lose the rook
if i move the rook i lose the night and
so what i basically have to do is bail
out i have to take his knight with my
bishop he takes back
well i'm a big 49ers fan big 49ers fan
and i'm still upset that they lost the
super bowl last year so please forgive
me
uh he is injured but i still have to
give him crap every time i uh
i have a chance to so i'm from the bay
area originally
uh and uh you know i'm a pretty
demanding fan
now what's going on in this position and
big warriors fan as well
no i love jimmy g of course of course no
no no i think he's great i think he's a
super good guy
i believe in him he's gonna come back
but i'm still sour please understand
that you know
now white is still better here who can
explain to me
who can explain to me back to the game
guys who can explain to me why
white is still better in this position
even though it seems like the worst is
behind
black definitely solving melanoma but
i'll get into that after the game thank
you ben mind b for the sub
number one they have a weakness on d5
what's number two
the number two thing is that he has an
isolated pawn on d5
and what is the thing i always tell you
guys to look for
when your opponent has an isolated pawn
what is the key question that you have
to ask to determine
who's in charge when you have an
isolated pawn that is upon which there's
no neighbors
do we control the square in front of the
pawn
who controls the square in front of the
pawn the answer here is white
why does white control the square why
can't black push respond to d4 well the
reason why
is that white takes the bishop he has to
take that and he loses the pawn
he can't push it okay so we simply
blockade the pawn with a rook
and he's basically got he basically has
to occupy
all of his pieces with the task of
defending this pawn which then gives me
the opportunity
to play on the other side of the board
and he doesn't have the resources
necessary
to uh you know to adequately
prevent me from expanding on the king's
side because all of his pieces
have to supervise this really really
weak pawn he can't afford to lose it
and in the end game the value of one
pawn increases tremendously so this
would be a disastrous response
so what do i do here we were playing
really fast at this point but what i'm
trying to do is simply expand on the
king's side
i've got upon majority on the king's
side and what do you use upon majority
to do in the end game what is the
ultimate
goal of upon majority how do you convert
what do you convert it to
eventually you convert it to a past pawn
right you make a passport which is a
pawn
that can basically go all the way to
promotion without
pawn obstruction pass bonds will not
necessarily promote you can stop them
with pieces but you can't stop them with
pawns that's the definition
king f2 to stop his rook from getting
anywhere by the way if he'd gone king f5
that's checkmate ladies and gentlemen so
you can still get checkmated in the end
game eventually i trade pawns
i bring my king up that's important
notice what i'm doing here
every time he's trying to get active
with his pieces i'm
getting my bishop back to f3 and
attacking his pawn so i'm forcing his
pieces back to where they were
keep pushing and now we get that past
spawn and that pass pawn is protected
okay that's the best kind of pass pawn
which because it can never be
attacked he's got no pawns that can
undermine that pawn
this is called a protected pass pawn
that is the ideal situation and then
again now he's in trouble
now he got his rook to a vulnerable spot
so i get my rooks as active as possible
and now i go for checkmate check and
checkmate
okay guess what is responsible for this
checkmate that's the protected passer
because he cannot take on g6 it's
protected
so that is basically what won me the
game now there's a lot more to talk
about here
but this game was long and it was
detailed so
i don't want to bog ourselves down too
much i'll take a couple of questions and
then we'll move on
end game does not just mean no queens uh
there is something called a queenless
middle game so if you think about it
uh this for example is not an end game
because all of the other pieces are on
the board there's no formal definition
of an end game other than the last stage
of the game
um but you use your common sense it's
like
if you trade queens and you trade i
would say two pairs of rooks
that's already an end game that's
somewhere in that general area
uh he probably could have drawn the game
if he defended
better um but it was very difficult to
do that in time pressure
if he goes rook takes g4 in the end of
the game was that a draw so that's what
he should have done he should have taken
with a rook
and we cannot give a check because we
are in check ourselves
i think that white is probably better
here because if you compare the past
pawns i've got the protected pastor
and he's got the unprotected passer i
can get my rook behind
to d2 and then get my king over and try
to win his pawn
but black has an idea here that can
probably draw him the game which is to
tie his rook
to the h5 pawn probably he could have
made a draw
but you know with in time pressure it's
a very difficult thing to think of
uh he shouldn't have taken with the
knight right if he ignores that and
takes the knight isn't it better yeah
probably
um i'm just looking for questions
yeah so white is better but with
accurate defense he could have made a
draw
um thank you phineas i appreciate it
how could you have exploited his
position if he didn't move his pieces
back to protect the bomb well then i
would have taken that pun right
um i have a general positional question
asks ryan ellis boyd when you move out
of the night
would you move the pawn out to stop the
bishop pinning it
i'm not exactly sure what you're asking
around do you mean a situation like this
where uh if you have this kind of
situation would you go e3 and allow the
pin
so would you go h3 in this position to
prevent the pin
is that sort of the question
um just to clarify is that the kind of
question you're asking
yes so you need to use your judgment now
i've given you guys a couple of tips
for evaluating whether a pin is
dangerous one of the top
pieces of advice for evaluating whether
a pen is dangerous
is is there a pawn that protects the
pinned piece
so let's compare two situations let's
compare this pin
to to
this pin right if you compare these two
positions
here there is a pawn defending the
knight here there is no pawn defending
the knight
it's a lot more dangerous when there is
no pawn defending the pin piece
because now your queen is stuck to the
knight now the moment black applies
pressure on the knight it's going to be
a lot harder to defend it
so that's going to be one shortcut that
you can use
and so when there is upon protecting the
pin piece you shouldn't be too scared of
it particularly
since you can end the pin with bishop e2
you've seen me do that many times if you
have a move like this in your pocket
you shouldn't be too afraid of the pin
there's a lot more to it but that's a
couple of
small shortcuts that you can use to
evaluate okay does that make sense